next category i actually let's go next
one
biggest clown all right i'm a head out
yeah
honestly gant could win this one i could
win i thought i was going to win this
one for the crosstalk i think all three
of us oh my god
opinion alone but apparently that didn't
work don't remember this let's check out
the nominations though all right
i was just asked right oh my god these
photos
i love how we chose the guests oh yeah
yeah we have so we have
me conor garn sydney and chris i want
chris to win this one i want chris to
win this one too i
would i would laugh if chris won i hope
chris wins it because chris would be
annoyed about it like yeah
he would joke about being annoyed about
it but he would actually be annoyed
about it
oh my god it's so
and i think that picture of connor is
about six years old yeah you look so
young in that picture
and this was last week
yeah this this will be pretty
self-explanatory sorry honestly i've got
to show this to the camera we're going
to get our money's worth
yeah exactly look at that i know thank
you ashley
boyce who do you think won the bet the
biggest clown
honestly any of these i honestly like as
much as i want crystal with it i kind of
think i want gone to win really
just for the crust i really don't think
for the crust it depends there's so many
different elements right yeah
i think you could also win it just for
being the monkey right yeah
let's find out let's find out all right
all right all right
wait who was second place second place
was crazy
58 what 58-15
seconds i was in a landslide what that
is the biggest win we've had yet
what oh my god
personal attack and i won't forget this
view oh my god
there's so many it's all flooding right
it's all flooding all the reasons are
flooding into my head of course
of course he's the biggest clown it's
not like i just felt a drink or anything
all right